[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 3 novembre
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
le déplacement de barbara pompili
attrape cet après midi la ministre de la
transition écologique annoncé des
mesures pour accélérer le développement
du photovoltaïque un plan danser en
plein coop 26 la conférence sur le
climat qui se tient à glasgow alain
bazot chercheur au ls ce sera notre
invité le lieu a démarré son activité
cette semaine un pôle périnatale vient
d'ouvrir ses portes à montigny le
bretonneux une quinzaine de
professionnels y exercent pour
accompagner les femmes dans leur
grossesse et dans la première année de
leur enfant
et puis la distinction pour catherine
lara à poissy dans sa ville la
violoniste et compositrice a reçu
l'ordre national du mérite la cérémonie
se tenait à la maison de faire en
présence de l'ancien premier ministre
bernard cazeneuve mais avant de
développer ses titres cette bonne
nouvelle à poissy le bébé de 4 mois
renversée lundi soir par un chauffard
est hors de danger c'est le maire de la
commune karl olive qui a confirmé
l'information ce lundi soir elle lundi
vers 20 heures le nourrisson a été
renversée dans sa poussette sur un
passage piéton près de l'hôpital de
poissy par une voiture qui arrivait à
vive allure l'enfant a été transporté en
urgence absolue vers l'hôpital necker à
paris l'automobiliste lui âgé de 46 ans
s'est rendu à la police dès le mardi
matin il a avoué avoir roulé sous
l'emprise d'alcool
[Musique]
faire face à la hausse de consommation
d'électricité et sortir des énergies
fossiles dans le cadre de ces deux
problématiques barbara pompili a annoncé
10 mesures pour accélérer le
développement du photovoltaïque la
ministre de la transition écologique
était en déplacement à trappes dans un
entrepôt cet après midi et qui est déjà
équipé les précisions de mélanie poquet
de célia gars de son gant c'est le
premier entrepôt du nord de la france du
groupe à être équipée de panneaux
photovoltaïques l'installation fournit
aujourd'hui 10% de la consommation du
site le groupe metro fournisseurs pour
les professionnels de la restauration
équipe depuis 2019 les auvents de ses
entrepôts nous avons un programme pour
réduire d'ici 2030 notre empreinte
carbone de 60% ce programme il était
initié en 2014
2014 2021 nous avons réduit notre vente
carbone de 31% donc on a fait plus de la
moitié il n'aurait disque en 2030 les
entrepôts de ce type seront bientôt
obligés d'installer ces panneaux
photovoltaïques c'est l'une des dix
mesures annoncées par barbara pompili
ministre de la transition écologique en
déplacement ce mercredi 3 novembre faut
dépasser les idées reçues montrer qu'on
peut le faire
montrer aussi par l'exemple de ce que
fait cette entreprise que c'est
finalement simple que ça apporte des
solutions à tout le monde et que on est
dans une logique vertueuse qu'il faut
faire deux choses pour y arriver la
première c'est faire des économies
d'énergie donc faire de l'efficacité
énergétique isoler nos bâtiments etc
mais aussi qu'on doit électrifié un
certain nombre de de nos de nos modes de
production par exemple dans les voitures
qu'on passe des voitures thermiques aux
voitures électriques mais ça ça veut
dire qu'on va avoir besoin de plus
d'électricité parmi les autres mesures
mille projets photovoltaïques sont
prévus sur des terrains publics d'ici
2025 l'accompagnement pour les
développeurs de projets et les
collectivités ou encore l'allègement des
procédures administratives pour les
petits projets
des annonces en pleine coop 26 la 26e
conférence des nations unies sur le
climat qui s'est ouverte lundi à glasgow
c'est en écosse plus de 120 chefs d'état
y participent jusqu'au 12 novembre et ce
six ans après l'accord de paris et pour
en parler alain bazot est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes chercheur au lsce c'est le
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement unités mixtes à qui y
est rattachée entre le cea le cnrs et
aussi l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines beaucoup présentent
cette coop comme est bien celle de la
dernière chance est ce que c'est
vraiment le cas
dernière chance je dirais pas ça je
dirais il y a urgence la dernière chance
évidemment c'est toujours un peu
spectaculaire mais je préfère dire ya
urgence il faut agir il faut vraiment
changer à fléchir les choses le plus
vigoureusement possible parce que comme
vous le savez on est sur une trajectoire
qui nous amènerait au lieu d un degré et
demi à deuxième 7 degrés à la fin du
siècle 1 et le 1° demi serait dépassée
dès 2030 d'ornement le 1° demi c'est ce
que vous évoquez a été notamment évoqué
lors de l'accord de paris qui a été et
bien signe en 2015 lors de la cop 21
l'idée c'était de contenir justement le
réchauffement climatique sous la barre
des deux degrés idéalement un ennemi ce
que vous dites c'est on en est bien loin
on sera pas du tout dans cet objectif
bah ça va être difficile il faut pas
perdre cet objectif de vue mais tel que
c'est parti à l'heure actuelle on va
dépasser le 1° me par rapport au pré
industrielle et ans le risque de le
dépasser de beaucoup on risque même de
dépasser aussi les deux degrés c'est
pour ça que même si ce n'est pas la
dernière chance il ya vraiment une
urgence à agir à s'engager
pas que des promesses il faut ensuite
que les choses se fassent voilà c'est ça
l'enjeu d'un cap 21 c'est définir les
choses pour rester en dessous d'un degré
et demi ou disons 2 degrés et ensuite
définir les moyens pour y arriver et s'y
tenir ensuite parce que le problème de
tout ça c'est que les promesses des fois
c'est bien beau mais après elles sont
pas tenues donc cette coque 26 va plutôt
dans le sens c'est pas une mauvaise
chose mais voilà il ya urgence et il
faudra tenir les engagements et on peut
encore agir aussi c'est le message à
passer on je le disais 120 chefs d'état
qui sont présents jusqu'au 12 novembre
mais on peut déplorer par exemple les
absences guy jean ping pour la chine
vladimir poutine pour la russie jaillir
ball scénario pour le brésil qui sont
trois des plus grands pollueurs au monde
la chine est plus grands pollueurs en
l'occurrence au monde est ce que ça
montre le faible intérêt peut-être aussi
que cette coque 26 malheureux à dire
mais ce sera peut-être un coup d'épée
dans l'eau s'il n'y a pas les os les
représentants de ces trois états qui
sont parmi les plus pollueurs ça montre
aussi le faible intérêt de ces états oui
mais enfin par exemple pour la chine je
crois qu'il a participé en visio un
peut-être peut-être la russie aussi je
pense quand même que la chine a
conscience des enjeux et la conscience
de la nécessité de changer les choses
parce qu'ils sont dans les pays qui sont
vraiment impacté par les conséquences
donc ils ont tout intérêt pour eux et
pour nous à ce que les choses changent
mais ils sont eux aussi aux premières
loges donc il faut que les choses
changent la russie ben je pense que je
ne saurais pas dire en fait juste c'est
évidemment dommage que le président
poutine soit pas la bonne le président
ball sonar
honnêtement je vais être direct il n'y a
pas grand chose à en attendre même
représenté sur place 1 il ya déjà eu
trois jours de coop et des accords
importants signés hier plus de 100 pays
1 qui abrite justement 85% et des forêts
mondiales dont le brésil dont la russie
se sont engagés à enrayer la
déforestation d'ici à 2030 on peut citer
cet exemple aux états en afrique qui
vont créer une ceinture verte de
végétation 1,11 million d'hectares du
sénégal à djibouti avec un fort
investissement public et privé justement
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler pourquoi
justement la présence de forêt justement
joue un rôle clé dans cette régulation
du climat pourquoi les les forêts sont
elles aussi importante alors les forêts
d'abord elle capte du carbone surtout
quand elles grandissent mais une fois
aussi lorsqu'elles sont établis petit à
petit a dû carbone qui est enfoui dans
l'essonne donc agrandir les forêts sa
capture du carbone il ya aussi tous les
aspects biodiversité qui sont
extrêmement importants 1 donc écouter
tant mieux si cet engagement est pris y
compris par des pays comme le brésil
mais après il faut que les choses soient
soient tenus ah voilà
donc mais oui
augmenté disons le réaugmenter les
forêts c'est une bonne chose ça ne
suffit pas mais c'est une bonne chose
mais il faudrait déjà que la
déforestation en particulier de
l'amazonie qui est réellement très
inquiétante pour pas dire
catastrophiques ralentissent fortement
parce que là pour l'instant
par rapport à l'année précédente
c +17 % de déforestation en amazonie
donc voilà la signature soit
effectivement suivis d'effets comme vous
le dites soit respecté cet accord lors
un autre accord qu on peut citer qui
était aussi signé hier 90 pays se sont
engagés dans un pacte global pour le
méthane pour réduire les émissions de
méthane est de ce gaz qui est aussi très
polluants alors l'objectif c'est moins
30% d'ici à 2030 on parle c'est vrai
beaucoup du dioxyde de carbone peut-être
moins du méthane qui est un gaz aussi
très polluant oui de bétonner et
polluants alors en fait à quantité égale
le méthane est un gaz à effet de serre
beaucoup plus efficace que le dioxyde de
carbone mais il ya beaucoup moins de
méthane que de co2 dans l'atmosphère
quand on tient compte de tout ça ça fait
environ deux tiers pour l'effet de serre
liées aux activités humaines causées par
le co2 et environs peut-être d'un pur
sang causé par le méthane a mais le mét
attendent accroissement rapide et le
méthane il a une durée de vie assez
courte c'est à dire qu'au bout d'une
dizaine d'années il serait aussi il
devient du co2 mais pendant cette
dizaine d'années assez courte cette
dizaine d'années il est jusqu'à
80 fois plus efficace en effet de serre
que le co2 ce qui fait que si on calcule
sur un siècle c'est en général se
comprend si on calcule les choses sur un
siècle on obtient un facteur 28 quand
même entre le méthane co2 donc il faut
agir sur le co2 c'est le principal
polluant climatique et aussi sur le
méthane il y voit là il faut vraiment
agir sur les différentes choses et aussi
j'ai eu le reportage de de la ministre
barbara pompidou c'est une très bonne
chose aussi d'agir localement comme elle
le propose et le méthane on peut dans
une certaine mesure agir il ya des
points relativement facile parce que
c'est quelque chose il ya beaucoup de
fuites notamment dans les exploitations
des hydrocarbures et tout çà et là des
fuites y compris dans la déraison
peut-être perdu alain bazot peut être
qu'on va récupérer la connexion temps ça
permet de
composer chiffré à 0 2 degré ce qu'on
pourrait gagner si on agit rapidement
sur le méthane une opportunité
effectivement importante pour réduire à
court terme ce réchauffement climatique
fait juste citer que ni la chine ni la
russie ni l'inde ne sont dans cet accord
sur sur le métal une dernière question
on sait qu'aucune coop finalement c'est
peut-être un peu pessimiste comme
constat mais n'a réellement réussi à
infléchir cette courbe négative du
climat est ce que vous avez quand même
bon espoir au début de cette coop 26 qui
va se dérouler je le disais jusqu'au 12
novembre il ya quand même des choses qui
commencent à se faire si on regarde les
émissions de l'union européenne en co2
se sont stabilisés et diminue c'est vrai
aussi pour les états unis malgré tout
parce que quoi qu en éditera un peu il
ya la conversion du charbon vers le gaz
qui a quantité d'énergie créée galles et
mais moins de co2 donc il ya quand même
des choses qui se font alors évidemment
faut pas non plus se bercer d'illusions
tout va pas être réglée en un jour mais
personnellement c'est mon avis parce que
ça ça peut se discuter je pense quand
même que c'est coop sont utiles parce
que ça fait un débat entre les décideurs
même s'il en manque à l'échelle
planétaire et ça remet une fois de plus
sur le devant cette urgence climatique
qui est vraiment là merci alain bazot
d'avoir été avec nous
mais je le rappelle chercheur au lsce
c'est le laboratoire et des sciences du
climat et de l'environnement
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité un centre
tourné vers la femme et l'enfant à
montigny le bretonneux un pôle
périnatale vient tout juste d'ouvrir ses
portes il est situé dans les bureaux de
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines une
quinzaine de professionnels y
travailleront sur place lors de
l'inauguration mélanie poker
certains se rencontrent pour la première
fois en cette fin du mois d'octobre
depuis le 2 novembre ces praticiens ont
commencé à exercer dans ce centre et
nîmes ont atteint leur point commun ils
travaillent tous autour de la
périnatalité travail en fait amp
l'odyssée pénalité travaille avec des
collègues et pas seulement tout seul
dans son cabinet et c'est surtout en
fait la prise en charge globale du
patient et dépassant les efforts et les
technologies qu'ils y ont mis enfin moi
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qui est
assez rare dans mon dans mon domaine
on a quelques quelques praticiens avec
nous moi je travaille avec quelques
infirmières voilà mes mais c'est souvent
assez limité en tant que psychologue
c'est vrai que c'est tellement
enrichissant de pouvoir parler avec
d'autres professeurs qui sont plus axées
sur le physique ou et toutes les autres
professions parce que c'est la richesse
de l'interdisciplinarité 14 professions
sont représentées dans ce pôle
périnatale les praticiens tous habitants
se partagent cette cabinet dans ses
locaux 2 175 mètres carrés à l'origine
de l'idée un couple parents de deux
enfants on a eu deux enfants avec ma
femme est en fait on a eu cette
problématique justement ne pas avoir
deux bryce est indisponible à proximité
nous vivons à montigny-le-bretonneux et
du coup c'était l'opportunité justement
d'apporter une solution à toutes les
personnes qui vivent à proximité qui
n'ont pas besoin de courir situé dans
les locaux dessus de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines pour le cherche à
compléter son équipe avec un pédiatre et
en gynécologue
ils ont rejoints et quevilly après avoir
roulé 650 km depuis les sables d'olonne
très jeunes de 14 à 18 ans ont fait ce
parcours à vélo au profit de la ligue
contre le cancer et beaucoup de
personnes est très étaient présentes
pour les accueillir à leur arrivée
céline charles et bixente mais rien
senti steban
[Musique]
une semaine à vélo et 650 km c'est le
défi brillamment relevé des très jeunes
dès que vit à raison de six à sept
heures de vélo par jour c'est avec
satisfaction qu'il revienne d'une course
avec son petit quota de difficultés ça
s'est bien passé se trouve c'était plus
difficile que les précédentes années
avec la pluie le ventre dans les chars
de on est content et on voit que ça leur
a fait plaisir aussi que c'est une bonne
initiative d'y aller ça leur permet
aussi bas d'encourager et de dd à l'orme
à leur manière cette cause une course
qui a demandé une grande logistique avec
plus de 40 personnes les dons sont
reversés à la ligue contre le cancer une
façon d'honorer la mémoire de l'un de
leurs camarades victimes de la maladie
soit sensibilisé c'est pour cela qu'en
fait on sait
mobilisés pour ce projet là surtout va
au décès du coup de
personne de notre âge qui est mort ici
que vit on a tous un parent un membre de
la famille ou un ami qui est touché donc
par par cet arrêt maladie
malheureusement et il était important du
coup bah tiens intéressés et puis
surtout pas d'essayer en quelque sorte
d'accompagner ces personnes au delà de
ce projet les jeunes ont surtout pu
apprendre l'entraidé la solidarité on
voit que nos jeunes aient quevillois
sont des personnes extraordinaires
solidaire et ce qui m'interpelle
énormément c'est leur jeune âge leur
jeune âge et partir comme ça durant
leurs vacances prendre du temps
je trouve ça vraiment exceptionnel de
rester solidaires nara cotée 5,5
millions euros versé un bon truc pour
l'année contre concerne ça fait plaisir
en fin de journée a lieu la remise des
médailles de la ville une fierté pour
ces jeunes qui envisagent déjà une
potentielle édition l'année prochaine
bravo je vous en parlais dans les titres
et catherine lara s'est vu remettre
l'ordre national du mérite la cérémonie
s'est déroulée à la maison de faire de
poissy vendredi dernier un plaisir pour
l'auteure compositrice et interprète
d'origine pisciacaise patrice carmouze
ce justin brasier et patrick jacques de
dixmude
elle est restée fidèle à poissy la ville
qui l'a vu naître et à son maire
vendredi 29 octobre c'est à la maison de
faire de poissy que catherine lara a
choisi de se voir remettre les insignes
de commandeur de l'ordre national du
mérite ça me rappelle ma tendre enfance
où j'ai connu l'époque nous on avait la
croire nous donner la croix d'honneur
quand on avait bien travaillé donc
c'est quelque part un peu cet enfant là
qui au fond de moi ça me fait plaisir
c'est toujours
un honneur d'être reconnu par les siens
c'est l'ancien ministre bernard
cazeneuve proche de la rockeuse de
diamants qui lui a remis la médaille
katrina est un ami quand guy tapir jose
tout cela a peuplé
mais je laisse donc
je suis venu lui dire à quel point elle
était une grande artiste
à quel point elle avait marqué une
génération
il ya quelques on l'aimait premier prix
de violon du conservatoire de versailles
premier prix de musique de chambre du
conservatoire de paris catherine lara
pourtant choisi le rock et la variété
plutôt qu'une carrière de musicienne
classique mais c'est sans doute à ses
talents de compositrice qu'elle doit ses
plus grands succès comme nuit magique où
les romantiques
c'est une virtuose de notre beau pays ce
soir c'est un honneur un privilège de
pouvoir honorer une des plus belle femme
de france que notre pays peut avoir
catherine lara c'est laid c'est la
chanteuse catherine valras et c'est la
violoniste mais catherine lara c'est la
belle personne une belle personne qui
s'est engagé courageusement dont la
cause des femmes et qui fut l'une des
premières à oser faire son coming out
répondant avec humour à michel denisot
qui lui demandait ce qu'elle regardait
en premier chez un homme sa femme
est le sport et du football les clubs
yvelinois connaissent désormais leurs
adversaires au 7e tour de la coupe de
france le tirage au sort se tenait à la
mi journée au siège de la fff et
versailles se déplacera à lumbres dans
le pas de calais qui évolue deux
divisions en dessous de l'équipe de la
cité royale poisse ira dans les côtes
d'armor défier saint julien un
pensionnaire de régionale 3 si les deux
clubs yvelinois se qualifient ils
s'affronteront au 8e tour de la
compétition enfin dernier représentant
du département chatou sera engagé dans
un duel 100% franciliens réception de
nanterre un seul échelon séparent les
deux clubs 7e tour de la coupe de france
les 13 et 14 novembre bonne chance à nos
yvelinois coupe de france toujours mais
coupe de france des régions c'est de
l'aviron le stade nautique international
de mantes-la-jolie accueillait cet
événement le week-end dernier est le
rendez-vous a regroupé les meilleurs
rameurs de l'hexagone et ce sur deux
jours retour avec nicolas landry et
michael et demi d'euros les joies des
déceptions des performances 700 rameurs
se sont donné rendez-vous à
mantes-la-jolie ce week-end de la
toussaint l'occasion de la coupe de
france des régions
donc chaque région fait une sélection de
ses meilleurs cadets de ses meilleurs
juniors et ses meilleurs seniors et
présente ici des effectifs de 16 rames
heures par catégorie d'âge et concours
en quatre et en 8es cumul des points au
fur et à mesure des régates le
rendez-vous était programmé pour la
troisième fois consécutive sur le stade
nautique international didier simon
cette année les têtes d'affiché avaient
fait le déplacement on a en particulier
tous les médaillés voir les champions du
monde juniors qui sont là et qui
représente leur ligue on a également des
olympiens qui qui sont présents et qui
ont tenu à démontrer leur attachement
aussi à la ligue leur ligne de
rattachement ou l'arc club de
rattachement c'est finalement la région
grand est qui a remporté cette 29e
édition après deux jours de compétition
en fait c'est vraiment chaque course la
faire à fond et c'est tout en un peu
difficile de remonter sur l'eau et dire
il faut se faire mal et tout mais en
fait on est tellement motivé il ya
tellement une émulation que bas au final
bas on y va à fond quoi
rendez vous l'année prochaine à mantes
la jolie pour une nouvelle édition
un directeur du programme olympique à la
fédération française de cyclisme c'est
le triple médaillé d'or de piste au gie
au flanc et un ruisseau qui va occuper
ce poste créé en vue de paris 2024
l'annoncé a été faite cet après midi
depuis le siège de la fédération à
montigny le bretonneux entraîneur à
l'insep entre 2005 et 2013 fleurs ou
soit occupé le poste de directeur haute
performance à la fédération française
d'athlétisme avant de démissionner en
septembre et puis ce mercredi 3 novembre
c'est la journée de la gentillesse pour
l'occasion nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des yvelinois que signifie
pour eux la gentillesse et quelle est
leur dernière bonne action est la
réponse au micro de bixente mais rien
senti steban et de justine brasier de
sur des vannes avec mes copains ça c'est
ça fait partie de la gentillesse de bien
parler par exemple dans un jeu comme je
suis étudiant en demie à part la prof
aux collègues de bien se comporter quand
tu vas dans les transports tu laisses
les gens sortir tu ne restes pas devant
n'importe dégâts sur wii je pense que
nous avons besoin de gentillesse et de
personnes respectueuses pour fonctionner
en société
c est là pour mes amis pour ma famille
être aux petits soins pour certaines
personnes
et puis aider au maximum comme on peut
j'ai donné une pièce 1
un sdf
le week-end dernier cette dernière chose
que j'ai faite quand je vois des
personnes âgées dans les transports je
leur laisse ma place quand j'ai une
place assise juste faire un sourire
parfois ça il ya une journée et
est très agréable et doux avec les les
personnes qui nous entourent c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant le cetud
société présentée par mélanie poquet au
sommaire ce soir l'apprentissage de la
natation chez les enfants restés avec
nous belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]